hey what is up guys mkbhd here and
tablets tablets kind of had a weird year
in 2015. we're all familiar with where
tablets sit in between smartphones and
computers but lately as they try to
differentiate themselves they've blurred
that whole line case and point what do
these three tablets from this year have
in common
two of them have the word pro in the
name they all kind of have this first
party keyboard attachment but really
they all really want to be laptops
this is google's pixel c the pixel c is
beautiful not gonna lie it's actually
one of my favorite pieces of recent
google hardware but it is the most
awkward combo with its keyboard so the
tablet itself by itself it's an
excellent build completely unibody metal
enclosure has the chamfered edges and a
really solid feel in the hand has some
nice weight to it too it's one of those
smaller tablets but it's solid you've
got the 10 inch 2560 by 1800 lcd up
front and these big stereo speakers on
either side that get really loud for
media or games or whatever you use it
for and even that dope always on color
bar on the back that behaves the same
way it does on the chromebook pixel and
inside it's all high-end for a tablet so
it's rocking the nvidia tegra x1 chip
and three gigabytes of ram performance
while it's okay it actually isn't the
greatest thing in the world it's fairly
normal throughout but sometimes apps
take an extra second to open and there's
animation stuttering more often than i
expected so it's not to the point where
it's a problem or it's unusable or
anything but i expected it to be
corrected with software updates and i
certainly didn't expect it to have this
problem out the box anyway
this is the keyboard dock it has one of
the more interesting magnetic attachment
mechanisms it's not really intuitive or
like a normal laptop but they're held
together with magnets normally and it
kind of sort of looks like a normal
laptop before we start to mess with it
to open it what you have to do is slide
them apart then turn the tablet around
and click the magnets into place and
then pull up on the hinge now these
magnets are really strong so once you
get it open like this you're solid it's
gripping that back panel with some force
and you can use it without worrying
about it slipping you can adjust the
angle and everything it works just fine
to put it back you flatten the keyboard
and then slide it off flip it over and
then place it face down and from there
you're good to go and there's actually
an additional battery in the keyboard
that's now wirelessly charging the
tablet so that is legit unfortunately
the downside is this is like the most
awkward keyboard for any tablet it
almost seems pointless after you use the
pixel c for a while i found myself
looking on the keyboard for like a home
button a back button a multitasking
button or even like any android shortcut
keys there's none of that the only
android specific button is just the
google search button this is basically
just the keyboard the letters themselves
for literally if you need to type out a
lot of text and i can't think of many
people who type that much on their
tablet to justify spending 150 bucks on
an accessory like this there's this
really great article i'll link it right
below that like button by ron amadeo on
rs technica on how this tablet the pixel
c was probably never meant to run
android and it was designed as a chrome
os tablet and then at the last minute
plans left us with this now android
isn't bad on tablets but it obviously
still has its quirks plenty of apps are
still portrait only and plenty just
don't measure up to the more functional
desktop or even specifically ipad apps
so pixel c kind of falls short of its
potential it's a bunch of awesome
hardware but it just doesn't quite fill
the shoes i imagined it to what's fun
though is even if you just get it as an
android tablet and never use the
keyboard you still get the side benefit
of being filled with a whole lot of
strong magnets enough to stick it to
refrigerator boom there's your smart
fridge now here we have the ipad pro
this is the most well known of the bunch
and it's partially due to the huge
popularity of the other ipads that came
before this one and ipad pro as we
already know is huge we've talked about
it it has a big beautiful 12.9 inch 2.7
k display and again an all metal jacket
just obscenely fast performance
throughout we already know the a9x is
legit so it's like the ideal candidate
to replace a laptop if any right it also
happens to have the best tablet only
battery life of any of the three
but touch is the primary interaction on
an ipad for sure there are tons and tons
of ipad specific apps in that app store
and of course they're pretty much all
made for using it with your hands so all
your games your productivity everything
with the ipad pro is by default kind of
done with your hands on the display now
i do have your first party accessories
you kind of can't forget to mention the
apple pencil which in all honesty is
objectively actually a pretty good
stylus people usually don't need a
stylus but for those who do use one this
is your best option for the ipad pro in
terms of performance and low latency i
just kind of wish it had an eraser and i
also wish it didn't charge like a giant
lollipop but all that being said the
keyboard accessory is yet again the one
that shows how much ipad pro wants to
compete with laptops gets a little
closer to a normal laptop experience so
the keys themselves don't have a lot of
travel or click but they're kind of like
the 12-inch macbook but there's some
useful stuff so there's a command button
on either side an option button a
control button and they all work kind of
how you'd expect them on a laptop
running os 10. so command t in the
browser opens a new tab command and
space from anywhere opens search like on
a mac so i can say that this one's
intuitive you're still going to get
handsy with an ipad pro though so the
keyboard case for 170 bucks offers a
tiny bit of extra functionality but
again you're definitely not fully
replacing a laptop now lastly here we
have microsoft surface pro 4. this
tablet is the closest to a laptop of any
of them it has a 12.3 inch 2.7 k display
full metal body again with a little bit
more of an industrial look and feel a
little more weight it has fans and vents
for cooling and you can spec it up to
full on laptop internals you can give it
a terabyte ssd you can go core i5 or
core i7 and you can go up to 16 gigs of
ram and give it intel iris graphics has
a full size usb port full size sd card
slot and full windows 10 so full desktop
apps the microsoft office suite the
whole deal so almost anything you can do
on any other windows 10 laptop you can
do on surface pro 4. so on top of that
software experience the keyboard
attachment for surface pro 4 is also by
far the best of the bunch to the point
where it's really part of buying a
surface pro you really shouldn't get one
without the keyboard the travel and
clickiness of the keys is most like a
normal laptop it feels like regular
typing it even has backlighting and the
hinge mechanism on the surface itself
keeps it at pretty much whatever angle
you want which makes it pretty great for
again normal work you do on a normal
laptop and the real kicker is this
keyboard has a touchpad with a
mechanical click and gestures and
everything so you don't actually need to
touch the display on the surface pro 4
for much of anything of what you're
doing so this guy is so well geared as a
laptop with the keyboard and the
trackpad that it actually kind of
struggles as a tablet it's sort of the
opposite of the ipad pro experience now
all the full windows apps are built for
being used with a mouse and keyboard
touch is secondary touch is awkward on
the surface pro 4 and pretty much any
convertible windows tablet for that
matter so you'll get the most out of a
surface pro 4 with that keyboard and
trackpad for sure so back to the three
tablets to simplify and sum it all up
you have photoshop express photoshop fix
full adobe photoshop
you're rocking android video editor or
imovie or adobe premiere in after
effects google docs iwork or the full
microsoft office suite you kind of get
the idea they all really want to be
laptops but they're not quite there
because they're not quite laptops for
now anyway thank you for watching and if
you enjoyed you might be interested in
the other tech of the year roundups
which you can find made by people who
you saw appear throughout this video so
juddner your average consumer with his
favorite headphones john tld with the
best smartphones and austin evans with
the best gaming tech of the year thanks
for watching and i'll talk to you guys
in the next one peace
you